emilio estevez was once listed among
hollywood's most popular actors born
into a screen savvy family that included
button and Charlie Sheen and raised
among other rising stars as the beds was
part of the brat pack a young crowd of
aliased actors that grace the screen in
a string of hit films during the 80s and
early 90s in recent years however
Estevez seemingly slipped off the
pop-culture radar here's how it happened
the outsider as the voz started some of
the most beloved flicks of the mid-80s
and even though the popularity of those
pictures lasted for generations
he's been resistant to rejoining his
former classmates for the celebratory
cast reunions that have taken place over
the years according to fellow Breakfast
Club alarm Molly Ringwald
he's the only one who doesn't keep in
touch with the others
even when there aren't any cameras
around she told Australian the morning
show the only person I don't really see
is um Emilio Estevez he really won't
have anything to do with this movie
she's just like that's the past and
that's not really what I want to hear as
well why he refuses to get nostalgic
with the rest of the pack Todd to say
he's certainly shown some social media
support for another fan favorite The
Mighty Ducks by live tweeting a crucial
matchup involving the Anaheim Ducks with
some familiar quack-quack
terminology men at work like a lot of
Hollywood stars
Estevez has invested inside businesses
to keep yourself busy when he's not
working on films in his case he quietly
owned a vineyard in Malibu making Pinot
Noir and other vintages for several
years with his former fiance Sonya Magda
ski as he told The Hollywood Reporter he
and Magda Basuki initially bonded over
making wine together
he explained on our first date I dug the
hole and She planted the vines there was
never any grandiose plan to start a
winery beings escalated from there and
they established Casa de Metz wines in
2004 complete with a los alamos tasting
room the couple ran the business for
over a decade
before they split and
eventually sold the vineyard in 2016 the
wars at home there's no doubt that
Charlie Sheen has emerged as the more
well-known of the sheen activist
children but these days he's more
infamous than famous Sheen has very
publicly struggled with the issues of
addiction relationship woes and
financial crises and Estevez has said
that he believes his duty is to provide
a healthy lifestyle example for his
problem plague sibling he told The
Sunday Times in 2011 all I can do for
Charlie and I can't live his life for
him
is to try and be an example but really I
was a pretty cool one as a kid I was
smart enough to be served Tisha's about
all my misbehavior or at least stealthy
but it means that my opinions carry
little weight with Charlie that's not
the only crisis
Emilio's been dealing with on the home
front and an open letter defends on
these films away in 2015 as the Bears
revealed that she and his family had
banded together to support his father
Martin Sheen through quadruple bypass
surgery to repair his heart that was
only a month after Charlie Sheen
revealed that he'd been diagnosed with
HIV and according to Martin Sheen the
family came together to support the
acting concision to reveal his struggles
with the disease the mighty dark
although both Charlie and Martha Sheen
got their second career wins from a
small screen starring in the West Wing
and two and a Half Men respectively
Estevez has shied away from television
even at a time when it's arguably at a
golden era factious of his ilk Estevez
did come in for a single episode guests
tense on each of those series but most
of these TV related work has been behind
the lens directing several episodes of
shows like CSI New York and numbers the
new way Estevez is written and directed
several of his own feature films
including the 1990 action comedy caper
pick men at work which featured him felt
alongside his brother his crowning
achievement came in 2006 with his Golden
Globe nominated historical biopic Bobby
about the assassination of Senator
Robert F Kennedy an event which Estevez
considered to be of grave
important to American history his most
recent effort the Apple mentioned the
way from 2010 featured Estevez alongside
his father who starred as a grieving
parent on a spiritual adventure in
France while retrieving his son's ashes
he's also been working to make
Cincinnati Ohio a new hotspot for
Hollywood movies in 2016
Estevez made a rare appearance at the
Sundance Film Festival to speak to
members of the Cincinnati Film
Commission about his hoax to bolster the
city's film industry opportunities as a
nod to his father's upbringing in nearby
Dayton Ohio as the most himself has put
his money where his mouth is on the
issue as he shot his yet unreleased pick
Johnny long shot in the city stakeout
Estevez has found his name and face on
the cover of many a tabloid over the
years particularly when it came to the
dissolutions of his relationships with
ex-fiance Demi Moore and his former wife
pod starlet Paula Abdul considering the
crowd he kept company with and the wild
antics of his brother
Estevez said he faced allegations in the
court of public opinion that he was a
partier and womanizer but that it just
wasn't true after suffering the
spotlight
Estevez has lost interest in maintaining
a celebrity or even knowing who the
paparazzi are following now even so he's
admitted to looking himself up online
and regretting it almost instantly as he
told the Guardian where journalists
think that he's don't read but it's
written about them they're mistaken I
would put my name in a Google site and
see what came up and Austin it was very
hurtful
Hollywood is guilty of turning up I've
turned it out myself but what the
journalists don't do is take a moment to
think that maybe this actor has got a
family and he has got to feed them
no wonder he's been so sure lately
thanks for watching couldn't dilute dry
country subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus
check out all these cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]